(peaceful orchestral music)
- When people say they
summit for the view,
I think they're missing
a lot of the equation
of why we do the things we do.
The summit, honestly, is
pretty anti-climactic.
(grunting)
The movement is, for me,
the most exciting part.
(deep exhale)
My name is Erik Weihenmayer,
and I'm the first blind person
to have climbed the tallest
peak in every continent.
(whooshing)
(moves into dedicated optimistic music)
When I was four or five years old,
I was diagnosed with this
incredibly rare disease
called Retinoschisis.
It attacked my retinas and
essentially unraveled them.
When I finally went blind,
(rustling)
it was a weird relief, like
the worst thing had happened,
so there's nothing else to lose.
There was a recreational group
taking blind kids rock climbing,
(clanking)
and that was it for me.
It was sort of the full
package of adventure,
all the things I thought I
wouldn't have as a blind person.
(clanking)
- You need 14 for this pitch?
- [Erik] Yeah, I'm counting 'em right now.
- [Climber] K.
- When I get onto a rock face,
I actually feel like I'm in my element.
The things that sighted people
learn to do with their eyes,
I’ve learned to do with my hands.
When I'm clipping a bolt to a carabiner,
I'm feeling it, I'm making
sure it's correctly clipped,
and if I fall, that that
carabiner is gonna hold me.
I can't look up the rock, and see
the holds, and plan a big route.
I can only see as far as my hands.
It's breathtakingly exciting.
(clanking)
Sometimes you hear those cars
way down below you in
the floor of the canyon.
I love that sound of emptiness.
A lot of external stuff
sort of disappears,
and you're thinking about nothing
but that next hold in front of you.
So it's very, very meditative,
very much kind of like
an inner mind sport.
(whooshing)
(clacking)
I like that,
I think that's the best pitch.
- Could you feel that space,
like, the exposure down there?
- Yeah, I mean, especially
with these trucks
flyin' by down there; it kinda echoes
through the whole canyon,
and you can hear everything.
- Yeah.
What do you say we top out?
- Yeah, let's summit.
It's right up here, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
(peaceful spacey music)
(clanking)
As a blind climber, it's really hard,
and you just sorta have
to embrace that suffering.
Blindness is just a thing
that happened to me.
I think, like all adversities,
we gotta use them as a catalyst
to push you in new directions.
It's the idea of turning
bad things into good things,
and it's something I
think we all could use.